russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
has arrived in the republic of congo on
an official visit he praised african
leaders for rejecting western pressure
to cut ties with moscow
it's the first visit by a russian
foreign affairs minister to the oil rich
country which is kept a neutral stance
on moscow's invasion of ukraine
russia supplies weapons and mercenaries
to much of africa in exchange for access
to natural resources
irina filatova from south africa's
university of kazulu natal in cape town
told us what russia wants from the
african countries he's visiting
well they want cooperation first of all
they want to convince these countries
and the rest of africa that russia is a
good guy
which is
benevolently
overcoming
the opposition ukraine's opposition to
supplying them with rain
so
uh it is a huge propaganda
effort
uh and uh also of course it shows to the
rest of the world that russia is far
from being isolated that is support it
is supported by many countries in the
world
out of the 54 african countries only 28
backed the un resolution to condemn
russia's invasion in ukraine is africa
playing
an indirect role in some way
in this war
uh africa is playing around a role you
know uh the during the previous cold war
i must say previous nowadays
during the previous cold war africa got
a lot out of the uh competition
and enmity between the two camps the
western and the eastern and it can gain
a lot out of
the present
tense relations between the west and
russia
and
of course they are hoping that they will
get whatever they can out of russia
which will be uh arms which will be
military supports which could be
uh mercenaries which could be a better
deal about oil deals gas gas deals
so they
hope that uh they will get a lot out of
uh uh not really opposing russia uh in
its invasion of ukraine
how far back would you say that this
courtship of russia's of africa
actually goes
well of course russia helped a lot many
countries in many different ways
during the struggle against
colonialism
sometimes it was military assistance
sometimes it was the assistance on
uh the international or in the
international arena sometimes
it was
monetary financial assistance so
uh yes
the african countries african leaders
senior african leaders in particular
still remember that but i must say that
in the last 20 years and particularly
intensely in the last 10 years
russia has put a lot of effort into
developing relationships with africa
russia sees africa as a
future not only a very important ally
but as a future
uh sort of source of not only mineral
resources but human resources and
political
the tool of political influence if you
think about the united nations and other
international bodies
uh it needs these allies and it has put
put a lot into this relationship meaning
if you think about central africa it was
in 2012
that uh sassoon gas
president of
the republic of the congo first asked
for russia's intervention and assistance
in terms of
establishing peace in that
area and look at what has happened since
then russia is now present in very many
countries in west africa and central
africa central african republic first of
all but then it is very popular in
mali in sudan
and
in the surrounding areas uh trying to
bring stability as they say uh and
taking away resources and uh taking away
any hope of uh democratic solutions but
at the moment african countries prefer
stability to any democracy
yeah they don't definitely sound like
deep friendships but but quite one-sided
as uh from what you're saying uh irina
filatova an expert on historical african
russian relations in cape town
you